so um it's been a long time since we saw
each other hasn't it
well it is right now yeah i'm busting
you popping over the weekends and all
the rest of that
yeah i miss you too dad all laura wants
to do
is to hug her dad but with him in cyprus
a new travel laws in place from monday
it's a hug
that would come with a heavy price each
time something like this happens
i just i just feel that
time is slipping away and
i know it's there for a reason but it's
really really hard
it's really hard and it's only a couple
of weeks ago that i was actually looking
at the potential of flights and just
nipping out for a weekend
just to check is okay to not see him
while he's healthy
and then possibly miss him
it's it's just incomprehensible i i
can't even think about that possibility
non-essential travel will be explicitly
banned
meaning people could be fined up to five
thousand pounds
for trying to leave the country for some
holiday sun
i'm desperate for a little bit of break
a little bit of um
a little bit sunshine a little bit of
relaxation jessica has had to rearrange
her family holiday six
times it's a relatable frustration for
many
i've got a trip to to india that i've
rebooked four times and that's a trip
that i've been saving up for 10 years
and
to get so close and then not quite get
there it's really
it's really difficult you're desperate
to go on holiday but
you can't i can't risk five thousand
pound uh
fine you know you can't afford it the
government has however accounted for
exceptions
you'll still be able to travel abroad
for work or study
for medical appointments to visit a
dying close friend or relative
and to attend a funeral you'll also be
able to travel overseas
to get married or go to the wedding of a
close friend
with holiday bookings coming in thick
and fast since the road map out of
lockdown was revealed
the already suffering travel industry is
dealt with yet another blow
the travel industry has been hit really
hard in the past year
we've lost 89 percent of
output which is more than any other
business sector apart from
um the airline and their travel sector
so we've been hit hard but there are um
a lot of people out there wanting to
travel there's a lot of pent up demand
and so we're very much looking forward
to when travel can reopen again
many people will comply with this new
law and not travel abroad
this summer but with a long list of
exemptions
and a pent-up feeling of frustration
from holiday makers there are now
questions
about its enforceability tonight the
government told us
it's down to police forces to undertake
spot checks at airports
across the country but we are a year on
from britain's first lockdown
and the likelihood of a holiday remains
at a complete standstill intimate
rasheed sky news